європу 23 3 вічно українка який на
кухарук проходило те бажання слухати
кому був дістали зі столу чоловіка вам за
у дикій міжнародній парламентській
стипендії якості уроку на даєте 120
іноземним молодим фахівцям 500 євро
на місяць ви тоді на проживання то
необ'їздний доступ до парламентського
кварталу на головному порталі не маску
панди ставу можна паба 6 напасти
німецькому народу vi обласний
вовни фразі і полягає вся вся
робота не моїх парламентаріїв і я на
своєю владою ж побачила ще робота
парламентаріїв на тіла на своїх ви
бурцев проговорити фасаді парламентський
буди вольта за будинком архітектура samba
лізу та transparent з політичні
системи
каталіна борячи нас особливою на екскурсію
тут депутати вбивають видам нашого
батьком та тунелем і приходять будні їй
будемо кригою лише її також тиковий [ __ ]
все можна доторкнутися то я в зал пленарних
засідань за 20 хайлендс буде який
точці придумав
у рядового кварталу також через ланцюговий а
вісь і сама пленарна зала засідань тут
які на розум жінки стажером з ти
жила за диво там і наноіндустрії системи
кіблу важливі вас розумі ти яку хвалю тебе
Рішення в демократичніше вкрай
як за стверджую ці обидва ці філя ці
законопроекти алое цнс і я перебував
часто сайту до часто там вже і так аж до
допомагала своєму оперу дружиною живота
різанини та групи видвидовача
приходив і дол депутата такому тілу
подивитись як функція а й демократії на
прикиньте 100 жування практикантів
запитують на екскурсію зал h тонкого
кунов чого глади дар задніть канцлера
ангелу меркель катарина захистів несіть
бачила трич і на її думку нині на ній
три maite вся європейська навіть підвищується
цуценяті там вчитися на їхньому пливу
кошторис
я до такого вже у тигра я увійшла в роль
сьогодні для українки в неї матч та
деякі на висловлюючи близькі з полів
таким частку del і суть не заразу
милості збоку на найвищих за по
саду та слух народу для дуже багато вода
ситуація була і частини їй практики для
монет уже вийшла його реалізувати його
своїй краї не я поміщу україна на
знайомитися раз спрямованому на вірний
чоловік них рівень має тарніс тайвін
повинен складати також до в дику тему так
зведу їх і бухту з дуба ти як і так
допоможе
базу - буду радий цьому карткову державу
весь ліс те бажання яке на кухарук
поварне сяду дніпроти проти атоми в
генеральному консульстві frn і в ньому ж і
новому це практика у верховній раді